[film reels clicking]
- Uber for Jen?
- Um, did you get
my destination?
I'm going to 91st and Amsterdam.
You're kinda going
an insane route.
So just make the next left.
It's coming up right here.
And, you missed it.
Okay, it's cool, you can
just take the next left.
And,
left.
Missed it.
Um, is this an Uber for Jen?
Do you speak English?
- Can I get a number
two combo, no pickles.
- And a peach banana
smoothie, grande.
- Great, thank you.
- So not cool.
Okay, neither one of us wants
to give the other a bad rating,
so let's just refocus.
My phone says you're best bet
is to take a U-turn
right up here
and go back 20 miles.
So, we're going to
make a U-turn, right,
You missed it.
Is this an Uber for Jen?
U-turn, U-turn.
And,
U-turn.
- I'm sorry Mr. Tyler
but we can't help you
with a house that's
that expensive.
If you and Mrs. Tyler
- Oh she's not my wife.
- I'm Jen.
91st and Amsterdam.
- Oh that makes more sense,
you said your wife was
nine months pregnant.
- Yeah, she is.
- She is?
Aw!
[upbeat music]
- "Clueless" or "Mean Girls"?
- Ooh, that's tough.
- Oh my God!
- Aw, I think I just hit a dude.
[upbeat music continues]
- Oh my God, look out!
[tires squeal]
- Look at that.
Close call.
- Oh my God, I think
my water just broke.
- Ah... Ah
- Oh, oh, Oh!
The head coming right now!
Waaaaa!
[baby crying]
Oh, 91st and Amsterdam.
Hey, my friend
actually lives here,
how did you know?
- The app shows me where to go.
- So you are my Uber driver.
- Yep.
- Cool.
Thanks, bye.
- Bye.
- Hey, Uber for Dan.
You're just gonna want
to take a left up here.
Yep, its right up here.
And...
Left.
Hehe,
damn it, that was the...
[applause]